porca [ __ ] e gli effetti ragazzi e
benvenuti che sono video sono fa vj il
primo video gameplay dopo il giappone
ragazzi sono tornato ho avuto la
bellissima sorpresa che si sono scassate
le cuffie mentre non ero a casa mi sarei
entrato qualcuno in casa non ha rubato
niente pro smussato le cuffie per te
sarà stato nate e mi dispiace bimbo
cazzo perché tanto esiste lo scotch
quindi topi intercooler niente regali
grazie a dio sono riuscito a rimediare
per adesso tanto in sti giorni le cambio
[ __ ] chissenefrega comunque continuiamo
con inside l'estero allora che a soli
eravamo rimasti che visto che avevo
appena parlato della mia fobia di e
stare sott'acqua è spuntata samara
quella di the ring ma lava angoor lo
mancata e non vale così sei bravo
ragazzo non lo schiaccia lo scatto
scherzavo
ma si coccola proprio peso forma mi ha
stuprato bene rimasta non scherzavo
scherza veloce zio veloce ma ha detto
sei stupido porca eva mataj minchia un
impedito sì però fate dei di dare delle
dazioni di quelle mosse che te ne
ricordi per tutta la vita dai
professionisti a sfondare il muro
rischio sfondare sulla tua madre ma lei
con la luce si caga addosso brutta tozza
a volevi hai capito ragazzo capito fermi
fermi ferin fair inveruno 23 east e la
tua vista poi vi chiedete perché rompo
le cuffie ma porca eva si cazzo questo
volevo quanto tempo per fare sta cosa
non avevo capito la storia della luce
scusatemi ragazzi sono scemo ma è
proprio questo già lo sapete
esci e madonna un'ora per sfondare sta
minchia di sophie tu escì per l'amor di
dio ti prego santo gesù benedetto e
siamo sotto mari dove cos'è una spiaggia
ce l'ho fatta non ci posso credere
quindi niente più mostro marino mi fate
uscire anche perfetto grazie stato bello
è 5 euro di mancia alla tipa consiglia
di pantene che ci hai capelli un po
umidi 2 minchia siamo regalo questo c'è
un'isola segreta cos'è asca bonn
permesso sono fa vj ho fatto un sacco di
strada o anche con loro
tutto conti per quei capelli brutti sono
vivo non si sa sono caduto da dodici
chilometri ma sono vivo va bene buon
salvemini ex alzo io non è che mi dà una
mano che le grosso se ne vada a fan culo
perché molti ragazzi sta gente come
arrivata quasi in teoria io sono
scappato da una fabbrica di persone
lobotomizzate che io dovevo essere una
di quelle lobotomizzate ma sono riuscito
a scappare
già non ci sto capendo un cazzo cosa
devo prima attivare la corrente ok come
relativo alla corrente perfetto salve
ragazzi un se checa sesto terremoto che
c'è ogni tre secondi sta succedendo
qualcosa non sto capendo cosa va bene lo
scopriremo più avanti c'è qualcosa che
che fa tremare tutto l'edificio non sto
capendo terno terno tombola cioè 19 18
in base a dove mi muovo di tiri fuori il
numero a se sto qua sopra i 18 ok sesso
esco fuori 19 devo raggiungere lo zero
ho capito se quella roba che sta
tentando di entrare qua dentro che non
vorrei scoprire le sempre più grossa
stago più grossa della mamma degli
haters e questa cosa grossa riuscisse a
entrare qua dentro in teoria dovremmo
raggiungere il peso
ho attivato la corrente vai zio vediamo
di capire cos'è sta roba
non è che devo buttare delle robe dal
soffitto di babù qualcuno mi dice dove
si ami prego datemi una mappa qualcosa
vi supplico non si capisce neanche dove
siano finiti cioè la roba veramente tra
giorno mi date una mano per favore io vi
libero anche però datemi una cazzo di ma
niente sono tutti automi deficienti va
bene ho finalmente sto casco della
minkia un'ora che lo cerco buongiorno
sentite one direction mi fate capire un
attimo una cosa chiesto che fa bordello
fatemi salire mi chiama tiebreak
bravissimo ce l'ho fatta devo adesso
indiana jones fantastico zio non ci
posso credere
mi sembrava troppo bello per essere vero
e una troppo agile dai zio dies dei
quali problemi che affliggono ne sono
più curioso di vedere che cos'è che sta
facendo sto bordello che che andare
avanti nel gioco e poi per scoprirlo
devo andare avanti nel gioco quindi va
bene deve essere un titano cos'è sta
roba
ci siamo ragazzi ma chi è a zombie
apocalypse o merda sono vengo in pace ma
kick ass fa ma cosa quindi io li comando
minova beh ma geniale che storia assurda
suicidate vi tutti messo suicidato solo
io pala [ __ ] allora la senso non ci
arrivo spingetevi no vabbè non ho parole
bellissime e venite datevi nave vi
prendo io li prendo io che sono forzuto
no vabbè come faccio a tirarli su cade o
girare l'ascensore va bene fermi e non
andate giù fermi non memori the first a
te gli immobili 15 uomini che per una
bottiglia chi ruba salih bravissimi mica
con che agilità in teoria adesso devo
portarmi sulla pedana
adesso mi so preso un infarto si sono
avvicinati sti due mongoloidi
adesso in teoria dovrei dovrebbero
diventare tipo 13 12 state fermi mondo
degli immobili non vi dovete muovere
dovete stare lì no dovete stare ferma ma
andate a cagare fermi o vi do in pasto a
godzilla che sta fuori
fermi di cazzo fai stretching o nova
loro mi servono per andare in giro no
scusate seguitemi va bene mi date una
mano a liberale zombie uno zombi 2
zombie 3 grazie no dovete a cazzo state
facendo
dovete tirare sulla no mi dispiacciono
volevo
sono un pezzo di merda commesso un
pluriomicidio a caso dalla parte opposta
dobbiamo ancora a trovarne 12 è in
teoria se quei tre sono ancora be mine
servono ancora 9 a temi su rega speed
date mi per una botta ragazzi bisogna
imparare a dialogare perché non c'è
comunicazione c'è poco manca quel quel
neurone che vi serve forte come a rugby
per famiglia fuori campo non suicidate
vi state fermi che devo vedere se trovo
altra gente tipo questo morto a lo devo
buttare ok ma questo è un cadavere
questo è morto chi spingo giu
finché ecco fa chi è magari era ancora
vivo sta solo dormendo però sti cazzi
ragazzi sto tornando giu sorry non
volevo che mancano ancora otto in teoria
poi non lo so andiamo a vedere se gli
altri sono vivi prima di tutto perché
secondo me si sono sfracellati tutti
ecco infatti lo giuro che non volevo
vita altro che michael jackson e gli
zombie questi sono ora questa è l'alba
dei morti viventi ora come è ridotta la
gabbia come cazzo fate servivi in teoria
cell è che infatti c'è l'altra gente
rinchiusa qua quindi se mi date una mano
perfetto fa chi è a ragazzi 11 solo ce
ne era da chi ma che sfiga quello
comunque non so se avete notato mai in
mutande due case hai lasciati pantaloni
zio lancia temi forte ce l'ho fatta
veramente non ci posso credere mai così
vai così vi farà super piacere sapere
che io ammazzo le persone quindi
capitale che facciata bene sono ancora
vivi i ragazzi fermi a chi è perfetto ci
siete fantastico anche tu sei in mutande
buona sa perché ok ragazzi oa sinistra
dovrebbe essere l'ultimo punto che non
ho ancora controllato a c'è una carro è
la madonna ragazzo siamo in 300 se
riusciamo a spingere stato fantastico
bellissimo the c'è gente che tira gente
meravigliosa ora salgo sopra e mi butto
sul carro
dovrebbe essere in teoria due persone
dentro spero perché se no non ho idea di
che cosa ho fatto a fare tutto sto
casino fa chi è
[Musica]
mi puzza la madre mi date altri esseri
umani per favore ho bisogno ho bisogno
di di uomini dove sto andando
che cazzo ne è una diga siamo
ufficialmente usciti dal pubblico
minchia sono finito legate cioè
occidente c'è gente
ciao gente devo tirare questa cosa e
venir via verso l'infinito tua madre
tozza non ci arrivo bene che ci sono
forse ho capito forse non ne sono sicuro
doti può spingere così non so ma ha
fatto venire in mente sta roba ma va
bene così veloce e amore la famiglia
vacchi e merda scusate non voleva boe
giorno a posto bene perfetto devo solo
arrivare alla porta ci siamo tutti
quanti vecchio keeping merci o like to
keep yeah chiami tira non so come se
avessi fatto il gol dell'uno a zero in
finale dei mondiali ci siamo ragazzi due
cazzo il cadavere è la perfetto ci siete
ne manca uno o ci sei frate nel momento
della verità ragazzi apriti porta
d'accordo ragazzi con quello che mi dà
vi starete divorando col pensiero mi
dispiace però sono un pezzo di merda o
propri l'episodio ragazzi se volete
continuo 50.000 like no perché questa è
una bomba chiamate anche la nonna mentre
l'ajax spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
cosa mi è piaciuto argomento è un mi
piace anche a pace di facebook e coni
notizia per i siti siete in ci mettevano
prossimo video ecco il karma il karma è
la ragazza